More than 1.5 million people have fled their
homes since war broke out in eastern Ukraine
five years ago.
But on the streets of the capital Kyiv you
would barely notice.
In spite of the fighting and a deep economic
downturn, Ukrainian society HAS been able
to shoulder the burden.
The refugee camps of 2014 have for the most
part been consigned to history.
Most displaced people have found jobs and
somewhere to live.
But as the country elects a new president,
Ukraine’s displaced people are having to
fight to cast their votes.
One of those people is Nelli Selyutina.
Five years ago she left her hometown Donetsk
in a hurry, with just a couple of suitcases
to hand.
I was driving to work with my husband.
Suddenly there were armed men blocking the
road.
They were really arrogant, pointing their
weapons at anyone who dared to talk back.
I told my husband to buy train tickets; we
need to get out of here.
It all happened very fast.
I came home from work and we left the same
evening.
When I locked the door I already knew that
I would never be coming back.
Nelli and her family left everything behind
- their home, their car and their jobs.
Soon after, Donetsk fell under the control
of pro-Russian separatists.
The family found shelter with friends in Kyiv.
But on their first morning in the capital,
their hosts had something important to do
- vote.
A poll that Nelli and her husband were excluded
from, because they were still registered in
Donetsk.
You see your friends voting but can’t take
part yourself.
If you are able to vote you don’t feel the
need so strongly.
But we were in Kyiv, the same people as before,
but without the right to vote.
That was really tough for me.
Since then Nelli has made of point of not
letting any elections pass her by.
But it’s not easy.
Each time there’s a vote she has to go and
register from scratch.
Like Nelli, most of Ukraine’s internally
displaced people are still registered in their
homes in what’s now separatist-held territory.
Ukrainian law ties voting rights to citizens’
place of registration.
But registering somewhere new is no easy task,
most landlords do not allow their tenants
to register and even if they can it means
losing their refugee status and the benefits
that go with that.
In the first round of the presidential election
comedian and political newcomer Volodymyr
Zelensky triggered a political earthquake,
picking up almost double as many votes as
the incumbent Petro Poroshenko.
It’s a nail-biting contest that Nelli does
not want to miss out on.
For the second round Nelli has to go and register
all over again.
In theory that’s only possible after the
results of the first round have been officially
announced.
But that would leave just a matter of days
to register ahead of the deadline.
Nelli has heard that some election offices
ARE willing to make things easier for internal
refugees, accepting applications to vote ahead
of schedule.
In the queue she meets old friends from Donetsk.
They too are desperate to vote.
Having a say about the future of my own country,
that’s really important to me.
We keep coming here and there are just so
many people waiting.
We keep coming back but the queue doesn’t
get any shorter.
Voting is my right but I’m having to fight
for it.
I think they’re doing this on purpose to
stop us voting.
This isn’t a question of negligence.
They could make it all much easier; put more
people on the job.
Here in this Kyiv election office the officials
are not willing to make any exceptions, even
for refugees.
Nelli will have to come back again, after
the results of the first round are officially
announced.
One thing is sure - the queues will only get
longer.
Experts say the current election law is out
of date.
Millions of Ukrainians live far from home,
some of them as refugees, others in search
of work.
Linking the right to vote to registration,
a legal formality that’s very hard to obtain,
is simply unfair they argue.
Meanwhile, a draft law to make voting easier
is gathering dust in parliament.
The war in Donbass has turned Nelli’s life
upside down.
In Donetsk she managed a chain of sports’
shops.
In Kyiv she now works to help other people
like herself.
Every day her organization receives hundreds
of calls from displaced people.
Many of them want to know how to make sure
they can vote.
We had many calls from students.
Many of them were registered at their universities
but as soon as they graduate they have a problem.
They can’t register back at home in separatist-held
territory and here on the government-held
side no-one wants to let them register.
There’s a big group of people who are shut
out of these elections.
These are young, active people - the very
people these elections are held for - but
they can’t take part.
It’s a problem Nelli knows about first hand.
Her son was just 13 when they left Donetsk.
Later this year he’ll reach voting age.
Whether or not he’ll be able to cast a ballot
- his mother can’t be sure.